And everybody, welcome to another Zoom call.
We're going to jump right into the questions.
If you have a question, make sure you just either
post it on the chat or mute yourself.
Well, that's jump right into the questions.
How long do the right machine bulbs last?
Do they burn out?
The right machine bulbs don't burn out.
So it's not as a gas-filled tube.
So there's nothing to burn out as it can desert light bulb or something like that.
So they don't burn out.
However, they can, you know, they can break.
You can drop the bulb.
Typically, if you dropped it, just down flat on itself.
It's not going to break. It's encased in plastic.
But if you drop it on the end, so those electrical cords go into the tube.
And they attach through the glass cylinder in there.
And that can break.
The glass inside there can break.
So if you banged the end of it onto the side of the banner,
if you dropped it down where the cylinder is going straight down,
you hit on the end of the tube that can break.
And then it's broken.
So that is then going to have to be replaced.
The other thing that we've seen with some of the bulbs over time,
especially the older bulbs.
I mean, people that have had them for several years,
the, it can start the cords themselves because it's, you know,
electricity going through those cords, especially on the older two right bulbs
where they were, where they, the cords curled around and then were zip tied
to the, to the plastic tube.
We've seen that, that, that, that burned into the plastic casing of the,
of the cord.
The cord has just gone bad and you can't replace that.
So the whole bulb just has to be replaced.
We've had several of those actually in the last couple of months
where people said there's felt they smelled smoke coming from that
and then they noticed the cord was getting really hot.
If that's the case, you're going to have to replace the tube.
So there's nothing else you could do about that.
What else can you do to damage the cords on the bulbs?
So of course, you could break the bulb if you really hit it hard.
You could break the end of the bulb so you look at it, you can't see any damage
because that is on the end.
Like I said, if you dropped it on the edge and you hit it at just right,
you could, you could snap the glass in there and all the gas would leak out of the tube
and you notice it doesn't work.
It doesn't light up at all anymore.
We've had that happen a couple of times and then you could burn,
the cord could burn and that has to be replaced.
The other thing is the ends of the cord where it plugs into the right machine,
especially if you yank on them and don't grab the red or the black
and carefully, gently wiggle it out.
If you yank on it or lots of times it's happened where somebody trips on the cord
and it pulls it out, that could damage that piece and then that.
That could typically be repaired.
Nothing else could be repaired.
Understand our warranty on the bulbs is nonexistent.
If something happens to it, it's user error.
You're going to have to cover the cost of that repair.
If it's a repair on the end of it, it's not such a big deal.
If anything else, you just have to replace the bulb.
If the bulb comes to you and it works and then something happens that it doesn't work,
then unfortunately that's going to be on you to replace that bulb.
Next question.
Why do I not hear anything from my right machine at different times?
And then at other times I hear a beeping sound.
Well, that's because the right machine makes different noises
and the bulb pulses at different frequencies.
And the bulb lights at different intensities,
depending upon what frequency is being used in the program.
So with the true right, it's running one frequency at any given time.
And if you're running very high frequencies with the true right,
you're going to see less light coming out of the machine
and you're going to see here less noise.
Now typically with the true right, you'll always hear the noise.
With the Atelier Robin, if you're running a harmonic with the machine,
so if I wrote the program and there's different times in your program
that you're running a harmonic, so you're running multiple frequencies at once,
then it's going to be much quieter.
And if it's a high harmonic, so if the original frequency is 2000 hertz, let's say,
and then at the 11th harmonic of that is 22,000 hertz.
You're running those two frequencies at the same time.
You typically won't hear anything.
So it literally muffles the sound.
You'll hear very little, I mean, you have to put your ear up to it
to really hear the machine.
So at different times, it's not going to make any sound.
And it's going to be much fader light, since you're running two frequencies at the same time.
So you may not even, during the day, you might not be able to see anything coming out of the bulb.
That's same thing with the true right, during the day.
It's difficult to see anything coming out of the bulb.
Now, typically at lower frequencies, you'll see that more intense.
And you'll hear it more intense, with both the true right, for the until they're Robin.
So it has to do with the frequencies that are currently running based upon the program that you're running.
We had somebody send a bulb back in the day saying that there was something wrong with the bulb.
He could not hear any noise coming from the sheet.
Could not hear anything coming from the,
couldn't see any light coming from the bulb.
And I believe this person was mistaken.
There's nothing wrong with the bulb.
They're mistaken.
So sometimes people go, I woke up at one o'clock, and I couldn't hear anything.
So I thought my right wasn't working.
Well, it's just at that given time.
The program that was running, the frequencies are running at different time.
At that given time, we're probably in a harmonic mode and a high frequency.
And that's why you couldn't hear anything.
And they may say, well, I woke up at one last night, and I could hear it going.
I had to go to the bathroom. I tend to get up at one o'clock.
Well, it was a different program last night.
So just understand that.
Of course, if you're at pitch black darkness, and you're running the machine,
and there's no light coming out of the bulb, and you're definitely in pitch black darkness,
then there's something wrong.
So all sorts of possible things you could have accidentally bumped the machine,
where the front of the machine, where you're instead of running on bulb or tube,
or on the plasma, you're running on the foot bath or something like that.
So of course, I can see anything coming out of the bulb if you haven't run it on the foot bath.
And a pretty good chance you could possibly damage your bulb if you were doing that.
So make sure you are treating your machine with good gloves,
and you understand you have a expensive, very delicate piece of equipment that you have to be careful with.
Sometimes it's easy to forget that when we get used to something,
and we're running it all the time, and we're used to something,
we forget to care for, like, it's a delicate piece of equipment,
and any bay eat around or bump into it, you can break the thing.
It's like anything else, so just be careful with that and understand that.
If I get a stomach ache after eating even good foods,
is that a sign that I have allergies to that food?
No, I would say no, so if you got a stomach ache, so usually a food allergy.
So let's say you have antibodies to a food.
Let's use gluten as an example. Let's say I have antibodies to gluten.
Well, I always get a stomach ache after eating gluten.
No, you won't.
It could take up to 16, 18 hours for you to feel any ill effects,
even in your gut, from eating a food that you have antibodies against.
So I don't think, you know, if I got a stomach ache to eating food,
I'll say, well, if I eat that, it just bothers me.
That'd be a sign of allergies.
Yeah, I mean, you could, it could possibly be, but more likely,
it could be to hypochloridria.
So if I get a stomach ache after eating good food, could it be allergies?
Yeah, it could be.
That is a possibility. Anything is possible.
But what's the most likely thing?
It could be hypochloridria. That's probably the most common thing.
I don't have enough hydrochloric acid in my stomach and I eat food.
It's not going to be properly digested.
It's going to go into my smell and tested improperly digested
and larger bolus and it's going to cause issues with digestion,
issues with absorption, probably increase in the,
it's going to be in a larger size and it's going to cause inflammation.
And that's where you're going to have more stomach pain or got pain.
Because most of your pain fibers in your intestinal tract are
what are called distention fibers.
So if the intestines are, you know, are distended in size,
that's what's going to cause, that's what's going to cause pain.
That's what's going to be the pain. That's why they have a lot of gas.
The gas is going to extend the intestinal tract
and you're going to have pain from gas.
So I would be more thinking of that,
making sure that you're, that you're taking a digestive enzyme
with HCl with your food.
There's different foods that are going to be harder for you to digest.
I mean any kind of protein, you're going to need more HCl.
That's why I typically recommend people to judge the amount of digestive enzymes
and it's HCl based upon what they're eating.
The size of their meal is a piece of that as well.
Certainly if you're like, no, I got all that covered.
I think it's just, it's always when I eat this particular food,
then for sure, then you could think of that could be some type of sensitivity.
Either doing a food elimination process,
or doing a Cyrex antibody test,
would be in order to see what's going on.
I have had having issues where I go to the bathroom,
but be on all day.
So multiple bowel movements per day.
Could this come from the black,
black, sad blood route,
black paste blood route,
black sad blood route capsules,
or the, of all,
aloe vera imbued that I have been on.
Maybe because I also take three to four of the atry aloe,
which is Cape aloe a day.
So the black, sad blood route,
either black, sad blood route,
or the aloe vera imbued will cause a person to have, you know,
multiple bowel movements per day.
Of course, any supplement that a person could take,
if you had a sensitivity to the capsule or something like that,
that could cause some issues,
but neither one of those products would cause bowel movements.
The atry aloe is a Cape aloe.
The only reason why a person would take that aloe is to have bowel movements.
So that isn't a nutritive product.
So the atry aloe is not something you take because I'm deficient in aloe.
It's not something you take to help heal my gut.
So there's different types of aloe vera.
So an aloe vera product like a liquid aloe
could be very healing to your gut,
or if you took an aloe vera leaf
and you put some of that,
you know, literally slid it open and put some of that in your smoothie every day.
That could be very healing to your gut.
Cape aloe is not consumed as a supplement
to help heal the gut.
It's solely consumed as a supplement to help you have a bowel movement.
So the only time I tell people to take that is if you're constipated.
So if you're taking three or four of those a day on a regular basis,
that's why you're having the bowel movements.
So yes, so the discontinue that
or drop it down to one a day and try to make sure you're having a bowel movement every day.
But you certainly, that's not something that a person typically needs to take on a daily basis.
Should I have any wide if I have cancer in the liver, small spots?
I just want a glass of wide now and then.
So is any alcohol a good thing to take for somebody who has cancer?
No, alcohol is not a good thing to take for somebody who has cancer.
It has no neutral to value.
Wide is got residual in it.
Lots of neutral to value.
Especially if you have cancer that's metastasized to the liver,
I would not personally be very keen why not again.
If I just had a glass of wide at my birthday party and a glass of wide at New Year's four months ago
and I'm doing a glass of wide a month.
Okay, you're within reason, right?
And but to like I want a glass of what I had one person once I just I drink some wine.
How much wide just just one a day?
What literally they finally had to drag it out of their drinking a bottle of wide a day?
Okay, that's wait.
One glass of wide a day is too much.
And if you've got cancer, especially if you have cancer in the liver,
you just don't want to tax your liver detox pathways even more.
I would say just within reason, but I would be careful with that.
Everyone is talking about methylene blue because the HHS secretary Kennedy,
Robert F. Kennedy Jr. is taking it.
Do you think there are any benefits to taking methylene blue?
I think there can be benefits to taking methylene blue.
But as you know, I'm not a fan of bad things.
And this is one of those bad things.
I think there's some data out there that methylene blue can be anti inflammatory,
especially to the brain.
There's some information out there that methylene blue can be beneficial for cancer patients.
You could probably find a lot of anecdotal information about methylene blue and cancer.
I don't think there's anything wrong with taking it in a situation that you're trying to deal with cancer and active cancer.
But typically the dosage of what people should be taking is just like a couple drops.
Maybe a couple times a day.
I've also seen these Instagram videos where people are opening their mouth and their mouth is totally blue
because they're taking like a tablespoon of this stuff a day.
Because hey, if two drops are good for you, maybe a tablespoon must be that much better for you.
Remember, this isn't a nutritional supplement.
So by definition, a nutritional supplement is a food or an herb that God has created
to either give us nutrition that we need, like a vitamin or a mineral,
or to help heal something that's going on, like an herb.
So, methylene blue doesn't fit into that category.
It fits more into the category of fenbenazole and Ivermectin, which are drugs.
Remember, so you've asked this question in the past.
Should I, you know, my cancer is stable right now.
Should I just take Ivermectin on a regular basis or have had non-cancer patients ask or ask,
cancer patients ask about family members.
Should they just be on Ivermectin just as a preventative?
And my answer is no.
I don't think so.
You don't still go on an antibiotics and save people's lives.
I can't argue that the discovery of antibiotics was a huge boom for mankind.
But doesn't mean I'm going to go on an antibiotic every day just because I don't want to get strapped.
That makes no sense.
So I don't think we're supposed to use things that would fall into the category of a drug
as a preventative substance.
Yeah.
If you had some weird disease out there that was going around that we saw maybe a few years ago
could methylene blue be helpful for that?
Yes.
Could Ivermectin, if I felt sick, be helpful for that?
In that case, yes.
Could Ivermectin and fenbenazole be extremely helpful for people that have cancer?
Yes. But remember, it's yes on some people.
It's not yes on everybody.
It's not.
They're not.
And none of these things are like, I'm going to take Ivermectin.
That's going to cure everybody because I saw all these testimonials.
Well, what testimonials did you not see?
The testimonials that it didn't work on somebody.
So it's, it's, you have to be careful with what you see out there.
Not everything is correct.
And a lot of these influencers, quote, unquote, they have no data behind them and supporting
them.
They don't even have real anecdotal support of some of the things that they're sharing.
They're just trying to get clicks.
And they're just trying to get followers.
They're not saying that everything's bad out there, but just be wise and be careful.
And I think be prayerful.
You know, we're supposed to ask for wisdom.
So when we pray, we're supposed to be asking for wisdom.
So we're not supposed to be ignorant.
Okay.
The Apostle Paul says 19 times in the New Testament.
Brethren, I don't want you to be ignorant.
And I've shared this before, but I know he's talking about spiritual things, but it's about everything
in life.
I'm not carrying that through that piece of wisdom through.
We're not supposed to be ignorant.
So not knocking the person and asking this question.
So don't, please don't take it that way.
But just be careful about everything you see out there.
And I'm not against Bethelline Blue, but I'm against thinking that we should just jump
at everything that we see.
So just be careful.
This was asked before and I did answer for there's other questions here.
Could fermented organic beef sticks be the cause of my mold or high micotoxins?
Yeah, so anything that can grow mold in it then could then produce micotoxins.
So, and then follow up how about cashews, walnuts, pumpkin seeds.
These are things I eat and my wife doesn't and my wife has zero micotoxins.
And I don't.
This is the person's trying to discern where they got the micotoxins from.
Was it from foods that I eat and my wife doesn't?
This is the kind of discovery I want you guys to be thinking about.
So yes.
So what are most common things?
Understand micotoxins are from molds that are growing either in our house on organic matter.
And then it's giving off micotoxins and then we breed those micotoxins in or food.
It's growing in food.
And then it's producing micotoxins and then we eat that food and we're consuming those micotoxins.
So each micotoxin are that list of that micotoxin lab test.
It lists the most common source food sources of that particular micotoxin.
Are cashews a source of micotoxin?
Well, maybe a walnuts, maybe pumpkin seeds?
I don't know.
I have to look back on that list of the micotoxins that this person is who asked this question what they showed high and see if they're listed in there.
But in reality, not everybody, probably not every food product is listed in that micotox report.
So anything is a possibility.
But it really has to do with the moisture content of that thing.
And could organic beef sticks grow mold?
Yeah, they can't.
If they're old, I guess we just don't know.
I mean, that's the very difficult part about trying to discern that is that some things you can't necessarily test for and some things you can't know.
So stay away from those things.
I know, you know, I have some practitioner friends that they themselves had really high micotoxins.
They literally will not eat peanuts.
Peasants are probably the most common food source of micotoxins.
Grains would fall into the next list.
I think cashews, walnuts and pumpkin seeds will be weighed out on the list.
And maybe organic beef sticks, but that would be weighed out on the list.
So I don't know anything is possible, but I would say barely low chance on all these things.
What do you mean when you say that certain foods are drivers of cancer?
So certain foods can be a fuel source for a cancer.
So remember, a cancer is regardless of what causes the cancer.
Regardless of what type of cancer there are certain foods that can be a fuel source of that cancer and that can change dramatically.
So let's say, let's say dairy is a fuel source of my cancer and I stay off of dairy.
Well, then let's say the cancer starts feeding more aggressively through the glycolysis cycle and is feeding more off of sugar.
Oh, then if I retest that and if that tests that way, then I have to change my diet a little bit and go more off of carbohydrates and not be juicy, let's say.
And then I'm eating, of course, you still have to eat, so you're eating more meat and then it could change in my fuel source of that cancer is mainly through amino acids, through meat products.
And then I might have to change my diet again. So a driver is just where the cancer is getting its fuel source right now.
And again, that can change. So that's why we suggest getting rechecked beef was listed as a no one by protocol.
Would that include grass fed organic beef and is elk medicine and buffalo OK to eat typically when beef comes up as a no it's no to grass fed and organic as well.
And it's a soft no to elk medicine and buffalo as well.
Now again, this can change usually when it come when usually when I test a person and it does come up as meat as a driver, I do want to recheck that person within 30 days because I just in my experience, it's it changes.
But it doesn't always so some of you may be listening to me and you are off of meat and you've been off of meat for a year or two years or three years and you're doing real well.
But at most people that would meet come up a driver, I want to recheck again because most people it changes quickly once we cut that out of your diet, clean up the gut.
And then a person can go back on meat. So we want to recheck that in 30 days.
There's a lot of talk of an internet about using caster oil in your belly button. What is your opinion? Well, I already shared my opinion about talk on the internet.
But this is been a hot topic. I actually saw a video of this as well. Now as you know in your binder, we have information about using caster oil packs under liver.
And people have asked about caster oil over tumors over their breast over and I told you to shy away from that because we've had people with some bad experience when you do a caster oil pack over the breast tumor.
Caster oil is really is actually a caustic oil. So it is kind of toxic. So if you took caster oil early, which in the past, you could see medical books back in the early 1900s would recommend oral table spoon of caster oil.
But in fact, it was recommended for women that were pregnant that they were maybe overdue in their pregnancy to take a table spoon of caster oil and it could help bring out the pregnancy.
And the reason why that is maybe possible is because it is caustic, it's typically going to cause you to have a bowel movement.
And just having that bowel movement, getting your balls moving was thought to be helpful with moving a pregnancy along and it may or may not have been true.
Typically, we do not recommend taking caster oil early. So I think it could be toxic to your liver, you know, especially if you did it on a regular basis, so we don't recommend that.
The reason why a caster oil pack works is that you absorb some of the product, you don't absorb it all that caster oil, you have a skin barrier, but it will help flush the liver.
So I think it can be beneficial, can doing caster oil packs on your chest, if you have a pneumonia, be helpful. Yes, it can be really helpful putting caster oil, if you have a really bad cough or pneumonia, it can be helpful to kind of flush out the lungs, doing caster oil packs over your belly and your abdominal area, could that help with bowel movements and help with detox in your bowel.
Doing caster oil in your belly button as kind of the new thing, what's the benefit of that. Well, I personally don't think there is one at all. So, no, again, I do think a lot of influencers out there are just kind of going with stuff because anything new out there can get a lot of clicks and a lot of followers.
And you have to be really careful with that. Like I said in the past, I saw an influencer saying, everybody should be, we need copper. So everybody should be drinking from copper cups and using copper pans.
Well, that that is not only nonsense. It's done right dangerous to make those suggestions. So you have to be careful. There's a lot of people out there that say they're nutritionists and they got some degree in the mail online or something. I'm not against that. I'm knocking that, but you just without any knowledge of physiology.
There's been books written on things that are completely physiologically wrong from, and then recommendations that have flown around the internet from doing, you know, taking baking soda as a orally,
a mixing it with honey or maple syrup and then eating it as a cure for cancer. It's just nonsense. And it's physiologically incorrect to, you know, testing your pH with your urine pH and buying pH strips and testing your salivary pH to get your body out.
But this is completely nonsense from somebody who doesn't understand the physiology of your body's buffering systems. And it's just dangerous thought. And so I'm here to try to rebuttal some nonsense that's out there and then tell you that, you know, there's, you know, medical professionals that say that nutrition is nonsense.
There's a balance between what's real, what's what's good for us and what's kind of just hype. And what could be possibly bad for us.
So this would fall into the hype. It's not bad for you. If you want to put castor oil in your belly button, that's just fine. I don't think there's anything wrong with that. But is that like a magical spot to store castor oil that God gave you? No, it's.
So everybody knows the belly button is to store salt when you're eating celery and bad to dip yourself. Sorry, that was a joke. But no, so it's not. It's so just that would fall into the hype category. And there's nothing wrong with it. But, um,
not about that next question. What are some steps to deal with constipation. So I do have a something in your binder. I think I think it's still in the binder. I wrote it a long time ago.
I know I have a blog post him on a call because I remember the title of it called constipation know how. So the main steps when you're dealing with constipation is never one with anything you want to go why? Why am I constipated, right? Do I have a ball obstruction? That's why I'm constipated.
Well, okay, so if the person had colon cancer or abdominal cancer in at all, that's the first thing you do it to be concerned. Do I have a ball obstruction? You have to deal with that first. You have to deal with the reason why.
Um, and then dealing partly with the reason why let's say, oh no, I have breast cancer lung cancer, or something has nothing to do with my intestinal tract. So I'm constipated.
Well, is it due to, again, you know, I'm having deficiency in the production of pancreatic enzymes or HCl, which is the most common thing causing food to go into my intestinal tract.
In fact, as a larger bolus, I'm having difficulty digesting. I'm not getting improper in improper breakdown of food improper digestion.
Is it because of, you know, trying to dig into the because of why do I have an intestinal infection? Do I have a testicle bleeding? Do I have a testing digging through all these wise, you know, process called differential diagnosis.
Let's say, that's not it. I just said some mild constipation once in a while. Maybe it's because of food that I'm eating. Could it be food that I'm eating that I do have antibodies against quote unquote food allergies? Yes, all these things could be the case.
Could I simply just have a magnesium deficiency magnesium deficiency is actually quite common magnesium is a cofactor in just about 500 to 1000 different enzymatic and metabolic functions.
In my body, we do use a lot of magnesium. And I have been doing a lot of sonas lately, or I have been working out of the garden and the heat and sweating a lot. Maybe I do have a magnesium deficiency and then I'm not having good bowel movement.
So start with as far as supplemental wise is just taking some magnesium before you go to bed. And probably the best you could use any source magnesium, magnesium glycinate, magnesium, valent, you know, two to four to 600 milligrams before you go to bed with some water.
Make sure you're not dehydrated too. So make sure you're drinking enough water that will help with constipation. If that's still not helping it, I'm having worse problems with constipation, then you move towards something like Cape Aloe, which I discussed in a previous question. Cape Aloe is a great
product to help with constipation. Some people will use CETA, except CETA could cause how it works as it causes contractions of your intestinal muscles and that could cause creampine. So I like to use Cape Aloe, it's milder and it works like all the time.
So those are the steps otherwise go back to the blog and look for constipation, know how you can see some other things that you might want to investigate.
One of the most common foods that can contain mycotoxins, well similar question we touched on before most common foods that would contain mycotoxins would be peanuts.
And again, it depends on the type of mycotoxin, but in general, you think of peanuts, grains, possibly coffee, anything that is stored and dry, that it microscopically may not be completely dry.
So, okay, let's say coffee beans, they're stored dry, they still have a moisture content nuts and grains, they're stored dry.
And I should say corn is probably the most common of the grains, stored dry, but there's a hollow center that if you were to take a laser and cut the thing open and use put it on your microscope, there's very large microscopically center that can contain moisture, almost always contains moisture.
And there's an acceptable according to the FDA, moisture content in grains that allows them to be sellable or have to be destroyed.
If they're too high of moisture content, it's pretty much guaranteed it's going to contain mold and it's going to contain mycotoxins and it's the consumer's going to eat.
How honest do you think some of these plants are?
The general males is testing every square meter of their corn.
No, they get 15 million bushels of corn and they test how many grains of corn and it passes good enough and we're not going to dump this and waste all that money.
So, we're going to use it anyhow. No one's going to be the wiser and they make chips on them and cereals on them into things.
So, what is the acceptable moisture content of these things? I have no idea.
And what percentage of them contain do contain mold and or mycotoxins again, the world will never know.
You can purchase, at least I know with coffee, you can purchase coffee that's quote unquote mold-free because they tested.
Of course, it's smaller batches that these companies are selling it at a higher price, guaranteed that it's mold-free because they're testing each batch in smaller quantity so that they can have confidence that it's quote unquote mold-free.
So you can buy that as I don't know of any company that's doing that with grains or anything else. So, it's difficult.
So, but the most common foods would be grains, corn, peanuts, coffee, I don't mind, can have it and different mycotoxins.
And there's any food that can contain moisture, can grow mold and can then produce mycotoxins.
Any thoughts on using the right in the greenhouse for plant growth? Well, yeah, I've thought about all sorts of things on benefits of using frequencies in other things.
And I've actually talked to, we had a patient a long time ago that did this and swore that their greenhouse plants grew better.
I don't know how you would be able to keep a controlled environment to run an experiment on this, but those kind of things interest me greatly.
I've just never taken the time to try to do a controlled experiment with something like this. There's a lot of factors that go into that.
But, yeah, if you do that, let us know the results.
Questions from the chat. I forgot to ask you today on my PET scan. What it meant when it said enlarged liver with none, uniform activity.
No, so the activity when you're looking at a PET scan, means the activity of the, whether it lit up differently or not. So, enlarged liver with none, uniform activity.
It would be that somebody is going to mute you. Sorry. So, if you have muted yourself, let me get through these questions that you could put it again.
No, FDG hyper metabolic lesions mostly blood pooling. So, there, that would be considered that there isn't any, at that point any metastatic lesions in that area.
So, if they say no FDG hyper metabolic lesions, meaning that they're not seeing that as cancer in the liver.
At an ultrasound of my liver a couple of months ago, it was all normal two weeks of treatment. Couldn't have done that, couldn't know.
But, pretty much everybody has some degree of fatty liver disease and some degree of liver dysfunction that you wouldn't see necessarily.
It's not going to see as a lesion on an ultrasound, but it can show up on a CT scan or a PET scan, but that's not cancerous.
I sent you my PET scan results to the best of my ability to interpret. There's no meds anywhere, but the primary tumor has a SUV of 5.5.
What's the significance of this value is 5.5, pretty good or pretty bad. That is used in comparison studies. So, it doesn't necessarily mean it's pretty good or pretty bad.
You would look at that on the next PET scan and see if it has a greater value or a lesser value in a comparison.
Next question. Last time you did a cheek swab, the cause tested as toxicity. You mentioned a couple tests for toxicity, but I don't remember what they are.
Also, Iverbectin didn't test for me, but Fennbenazole did. Is there anything else like Iverbectin that works synergistically with Fennbenazole?
I don't think that Iverbectin works synergistically with Fennbenazole.
So, I don't know of anything that works. The things that work synergistically with Fennbenazole are typically thought of as like curcumin can, vitamin E can, burberry can, CBD can.
But I don't believe Fennbenazole that Iverbectin is a synergistic beneficial component of the Fennbenazole protocol. There are two different things.
So, something that works synergistically with it is something that increases the effectiveness of one or both products.
So, curcumin, for instance, can increase the effectiveness of Fennbenazole. But I don't think Iverbectin increases the effectiveness of Fennbenazole, nor does Fennbenazole increase the effectiveness of Iverbectin.
Next question. I'm hoping to understand more about the right machine operation. I use a weighted blanket. Does the light need to have direct, straight direct contact with me? Or is it okay if the weighted blanket is between me and the light?
So, I believe that the frequencies are still going to go through the blanket, but the more things that the frequencies have to go through, the less benefit that a person is going to have.
But understand in saying that, what benefit do you need from the right machine? You need the frequencies to hit and penetrate your body.
So, the frequencies hit and penetrate my body and penetrate and have the same effectual effect on my cancer cells, if I have a direct, not impeded access to my body.
Well, there is a balance that you have to go through there, because we're going to use a machine that has more voltage, more amperage, and it's going to penetrate my body and penetrate the bed and penetrate the floor and go underneath the floor to the bedroom in the basement.
That's kind of overkill, right? So, I just need it to affect me, and that's my whole purpose with that. However, it's difficult to measure, it's impossible to measure with everything it's going through just through your skin and through your fat layers and through your muscle layers and through your bone, the direct effect on the cancer itself.
So, I always think you're better off airing and having the bulb as close to you as possible. There is a law in physics that every, I think it's every, I don't know, every foot that it's away, you're going to have the energy that's going to hit something like that, I don't remember the law.
So, the more things you're going through, you're going to filter some of that energy that's hitting your body as well. So, I always think that closer it is to your body and the more direct you have that light to your body, the better off it's going to be.
Now, that being said, there's times that you're running different frequencies that it can, it can take a lot on you because it is really hitting you hard and having a big physiological effect on your body.
And there's times that you may feel like you want to set the bulb a little bit farther away because you're possibly almost getting like a hexagonal type reaction because you may be killing cells or killing bacteria and things.
Certainly with diseases like Lyme disease where you're killing gram negative bacteria, that is very commonly seen. And I have to tell those people to actually put the bulb under the bed because we do want some filtration of those frequencies.
So, that we don't kill gram negative bacteria to quickly and liberate lipopolysaccharides. So, it's pretty hard to argue that it's not having an effect. I think when you're trying to kill cancer, you want it as close to you as possible.
That's just my understanding that's how I've always recommended its use.
Next question, by son and I are both patients of yours. He is for acting in myself for cancer. We are on similar diets being gluten and dairy free.
Is it okay to eat a food that does not have gluten in it but is but on the label it says processed in a facility with wheat etc.
He can't have sorghum or sesame seeds and lots of labels have the warning on them. So, we aren't sure if he could eat it if sorghum and sesame seeds weren't an ingredient.
But it was still made in a facility that processed those things. It may be different for him with acting versus me with cancer.
So, it depends on how reactive a person is. So, many people that show a lot of antibodies. If so, if they do is Syrex 3x and Syrex 4.
And they show a lot of antibodies on the 3x, which is the gluten and gliated antibody and the gliated peptide tests.
So, you're testing different peptides for gliated and you're any sensitive to a lot of those things.
The food says it's made in a facility with these things but it is gluten free because it doesn't have any gluten in the ingredients.
It means that there could be cross contamination. So, it's really buyer beware of those things.
So, for a period of time, you may want to even stay away from those things. I've had people that are full of celiac and the difference between that and a gluten sensitivity is a celiac person has had a biopsy of their testicle wall and they have, you know, shows the antibodies to gliated.
Then they can't even, some of those people can't even walk by a bakery and breathe in any gluten dust and they'll, because they'll have a reaction.
So, but again, when people are dealing with something like this, it's not necessarily noticing any type of reaction done in celiac patients but trying to really clean out their gut.
So, for a period of time, you may want to choose to be more careful of cross-reactive foods as well.
And then you get to a point where you don't have to be careful of those cross-reactive foods.
So, yeah, it's a hard question to answer. You want to be a purist that you're staying away from anything if it's made even in a factory with those things.
Apparently, when I tell you to stay away from gluten as a cancer patient, then you don't have to take that kind of worry of that.
We're talking about gluten being a driver. It's if there's cross contamination, it's not enough to cause any cancer driving capabilities.
Next question. An ecologist recommended I try acupuncture for neuropathy. Do you have any knowledge or opinions about this approach?
Acupuncture for neuropathy.
So, maybe it could work. I did acupuncture in my practice for 20 years.
And I've done acupuncture since I graduated 39 years ago. I haven't done acupuncture very often in the last multiple years.
Has acupuncture ever worked for neuropathy?
No, but there's probably better acupuncturists than I am.
So, they may have some experience and I would certainly give it a try. There's no harm in it.
So, I would certainly give it a try.
There's no downsides. So, yeah, see, let me know. Feed back what it, if it worked or not.
What are the tests to measure toxicity? Well, it depends on what toxicity you're looking for.
So, there are different inner poisons that were exposed to that is measured in a test.
We typically use mosaic ms for that. There's a tox detect test that we run on patients that tests, I don't know, 30, 25 different poisons that are in our environment.
There's a glyphosate test in itself that stands by itself to measure glyphosates.
There's mycotoxin test that is very valuable because we talked about that in multiple questions today.
Mycotoxins are carcinogens. So, measuring mycotoxins, if you have current exposure to mycotoxins that have never been dealt with,
and you have high levels of mycotoxin that can certainly be something that you want to address.
Heavy metal testing is another possible test that you may want to look at.
So, there's different toxicity tests that you could do.
If you call the office, Maureen can point you to one of the tests.
I might have to get it up on this door as a stand alone. I'll have to look and see what we have.
Those are the kind of tests that you do. Those are urine tests.
So, those are the kind of toxicity tests that I'm talking about.
Probably the most relative to you would be tox detect test and mycotoxin test.
Those are going to be the most relevant to somebody that has cancer, dealing with those type of toxins.
The glyphosate test, we did everybody for a while that I actually pulled it off simply because everybody was positive.
And now we're doing it again just to show that.
Some people have a struggle with that because how could I be positive on glyphosate?
So, glyphosate is rolled up, which is an herbicide that is going to be folded not organic foods.
I've never had people normal on glyphosate and some people struggle with that.
Like, how could this possibly be? I've been eating nothing but organic food for the last X years.
But truth is, there's so much cross contamination.
The other different toxins can be based upon a person's exposure.
Whether you work with chemicals, you're going to obviously have a much more higher toxic load.
If a person that I could ever work with chemicals, but you're still exposed to toxins everywhere.
From flame retardants in your carpeting, to your clothing, to what's coming off.
Theumes that are coming off your walls to your new comforter, your bought.
These things dissipate into our airspace. We breathe them in.
So, we're exposed to so many poisons in our environment that have made our life considerably easy in a first world country.
But then, the cause that are basically poisons.
So, testing for these aren't necessarily something not all these things you can like magically just hold.
I'm not going to let myself be exposed to those things.
But it does give us clues that we just don't detoxify some things very well.
And we need to support those pathways better.
So, is it the gluten we're staying away from in wheat?
Naturally, or is it the glutamine that is sprayed on wheat that's bad?
We have access to organic wheat berry milled flour.
So, no, some people have said and you've probably seen it out there that gluten sensitivity is nonsense.
It's really the glyphosate that's sprayed on wheat that people are reacting to.
Well, I agree that there's probably a lot of people that are reacting to the glyphosate sprayed on wheat.
Therefore, we should be before buying wheat, we should be buying organic wheat berries and organic flour.
So, we should be buying organic everything, if possible, because especially grains are going to be sprayed with glyphosates.
Not glutamine, I think you're talking about glyphosate.
So, that's roundup again.
So, yes, we should be buying those things organic.
But, if I had listed in your cancer cheek swamp test that you have to stay away from gluten,
it is nothing to do with the glyphosate.
It's that gluten is the driver.
So, why would gluten be a driver?
Well, gluten, I technically isn't a quote-unquote driver, but it's what gluten does to you that causes the cancer to grow.
Because if a person has a gluten issue, it could cause every time you eat it, it's going to cause inflammation, both in your brain and in your gut.
So, gluten and dairy have morphine receptors in the brain.
So, you have what are called gluteal morphine and caseal morphine receptors that go right to the brain and are going to cause inflammation in the brain.
So, if you have casey sensitivity or gluten sensitivity, you're going to cause brain inflammation and you're going to cause intestinal inflammation,
you're going to cause bodily inflammation.
And now, you're going to make person with cancer active fight this immune reaction at multiple ends.
And the army is going to have a better chance of losing the battle.
So, when I tell you in your cheek swab test and in your binder to stay away from dairy, there's multiple reasons why you're staying away from dairy.
Dairy can be a driver, dairy can be a source of inflammation and mucus production, dairy can increase different growth pathways.
Gluten is going to, if I tell you to stay away from gluten, it's mainly because of inflammatory pathways.
And then, gluten is highly inflammatory to the brain and it's a molecular mimic to different antibody production.
When a person has thyroid issues, even if they just have primary hypothyroidism, they shouldn't be eating gluten because gluten is a molecular mimic to the thyroid.
So, the chance of you moving from primary hypothyroidism to Hashimoto's is pretty high if you're continuing to eat gluten if you have primary hypothyroidism.
So, understand, primary hypothyroidism, you have a low functioning thyroid but you don't have antibodies to the thyroid yet.
Hashimoto's is now you have antibodies to the thyroid.
Likewise, when you have neurological antibodies, you have antibodies to neurological tissue like myelin, sheath, antibodies and some other antibodies to different neurological tissue.
It's across reacted to that antibody.
So, gliadin and gliadin peptides can be across reacted to that neurological antibody.
So, every time you eat gluten, you're causing more inflammation in the brain and direct destruction of the neurological structures that which you have antibodies against.
So, if you have myelin, sheath antibodies and you continue to eat gluten, you're going to you're going to end up with the you know more of a demyelinated disease.
You're going to end up with progression of your multiple sclerosis and you're going to end up with further degeneration of the brain.
So, gluten could be a bad player in that arena.
Is gluten ever a direct fuel source by itself to the cancer? No, it's an indirect driver, I would say, or indirect influencer of cancer because of the inflammatory process.
Well, but what if I buy organic wheat? Is that going to cause the same problem? Yes, because organic wheat is still has the protein called gliadin in it, whether it's you know,
related with glyphosate or not is different. So, it is meaningless. So, it's still a problem. So, even if it's great organic source wheat.
Some people have said, well, you know, I react to gluten, but I don't react to gluten from wheat from France or Italy.
Well, the reason is is because that is an older form of grain that encases the gliadin tighter. It doesn't liberate as much gliadin.
However, if a person has antibodies to the thyroid and or primary hypothyroidism or antibodies to neural tissue, it still doesn't make any difference. You still can't eat that.
But if a person doesn't have any of those antibodies has no thyroid issues and just does show gluten sensitivity, still if they show antibodies in the Syrex 3x test,
you still can't eat these ancient grains, you still can't. However, let's say you do a Syrex 3x, you don't have any antibodies, but you know,
gluten isn't really good for us. So, you've been staying away from gluten. You do not have any neurological brain antibodies.
Nor do you have any issues with your thyroid. Could you eat some ancient wheat or could you eat some wheat that is from Europe, France and Italy that has, that is basically more the ancient grains?
Probably yes, you probably could. Too much of any of that could spark a gluten sensitivity, so you have to be careful with that. But yeah, you'd probably be okay in that case, but that's really not the cases we're talking about.
Okay, I think that will be it for tonight. Thanks for the great questions and we will talk again next week. All right. Bye-bye.